i want you all to be bouvons okay lavon
is a girl's name
you need to shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]
i knew it
i go for pony
[Music]
when you talk about it it seems weird
[Laughter]
wow what the hell
hey camera b camera oh
they set speeding
speeding
can you deal with this
ah
[Laughter]
i love you
you don't call [ __ ] people retarts
it's bad taste
you call your friends retards
[Laughter]
here's your headline
scranton paper company
dunder mifflin apologizes to valued
client
some companies still know how
business is done
it's more like the whole article
over the gums and through the lips
look out stomach
there we go
[Laughter]
my uncle harvey schrute
is a fudge packer
he works at the hershey factory
now i know what you're thinking
won't that just shed more light on the
penises but you know what
that's a risk
we have today
[Laughter]
that is a risk that we have to no no no
i know what you're saying why do you
keep going
hey i know what you're thinking won't
that just shut down
i know what you're thinking won't that
just shed more light on the penises but
that is a risk we need to take
pam thank you
pam why don't you work with palace and
draw a picture of the exposure
i want it on my desk by the end of the
day or you will receive a full
desaturation
what's that
i love the way john cracks
we had a funeral for a bird
i'm pretty sure none of that's real
you're not real
huh
do we have any muffins
yeah
take a longer pause before you answer
pat
i don't know if you like country music
but i was thinking maybe one of these
days
god bless america
would you please sign my company
directory
i'm about people
okay
good
[Laughter]
something like that the hell is that
i don't mean to be crass but get
prepared to get wet
because
oh my god
wow
there was no double meaning in that
there wasn't you couldn't even get
through it
it's the most horrible thing i'm so
sorry
oh hey kate are you holding up
pretty good paul what's up
oh my gosh i have so much to tell you
yeah tom cruise and katie holmes had a
baby and they named it shiloh and brad
pitt and angelina they had a baby too
and they named it suri
i think you have those mixed up
either this chick is a dude or halpert
went got scared straight got a little
lines come on hector
all right i'm the i'm the candy man
santa's come early
sure santa santa would like to bear
santa would like to buy you a pair of
panties little girl
shannon
[Laughter]
when it came out for soccer practice
i i pinched him
where did you pinch him
where would you like the rice krispie
treat stars they're sugar plum fairy
wands
sugars
sugar plum
fairy wand sugar
oh my god
[Laughter]
phyllis
yogurt container
fellas yogurt container
[Laughter]
now naturally he hopes he can count on
your discretion intuitively
cute man
i don't know it seems a little shady
well it's all you can eat
play soccer
okay
[Laughter]
so
you all want to know what i was in for
no no hey
are you busy what do you mean we're
rolling melissa how are you i thought
somebody just said mel so you all want
to
[Laughter]
know i locked it
this is toby
this is toby
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
[Laughter]
jimbo last chance of carpool
sorry
you want carpool
[Laughter]
will carpool together
i'm going sebring
no mom
[Laughter]
carpool
will carpool together yeah
i'll meet you there
[Laughter]
sabotage
what are you saying are you saying
sandwich
no i was saying that before
are you okay
i'm sorry it made me laugh so hard to
see him say it sabotage
okay i got it now i got it
sabotage
what are you saying
i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry looking at american biomed
i don't see that the minimum quality
hey hey
what's different about you
you look worse
thank you
you got a
haircut talk me through an appendectomy
step one disinfect step two incision
step three locate the source of the
infection step three tenderly remove the
appendix so it's not
sorry
dude i could help you
twice
it was perfect
i didn't even know so funny
i have to pull a u-turn
because we have been driving the wrong
way
[Laughter]
pam
beasley or like pam babley
you're cute okay
did you break wind that wasn't me okay
whew that is pungent
[Laughter]
you